[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich dachte mir, heute, der letzte Sonntag in diesem Jahr,
gibt es ein Nachgemacht-Rezept
und dieses Mal machen wir Reese's nach.
Die hat sich der Murat wirklich schon sehr lange gewünscht.
Auch hier an dieser Stelle:
Es ist keine bezahlte Produktplatzierung.
Ich kopiere das Produkt.
Bitte zeigt mich nicht an.
Das muss man dazusagen.
Weil die meisten denken dann:
"Oh, jetzt wird sie bezahlt dafür. Deswegen macht sie das."
Nein, ich mache es nach, weil ihr euch das wünscht,
Nachgemacht-Rezepte.
Und ja,
und der Murat hat sich es auch gewünscht.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Also Reese's sind ja Peanut Butter Cups,
also Erdnussbutter-Schälchen
mit Schokolade.
Von den Zutaten her: natürlich Milchschokolade,
dann alles andere,
dann die Peanut Butter Cream Center.
Ja, also im Prinzip außenrum Schokolade,
in der Mitte
– eigentlich dürfte es ja gar nicht so schwer sein.
Weil ich denke, es ist einfach außen Vollmilchschokolade,
innen Erdnussbutter und das war es.
Komm. Das eine ist leider schon ein bisschen zerstört.
Ich muss, glaube ich, nur schon von vornherein sagen:
Ich bin ja mehr Zartbitterschokoladen-Fan.
Ich würde sie vielleicht mit Zartbitter nachmachen.
[Musik]
So sehen sie aus.
Hä? Der hat ja gar keinen Boden!
Der hat praktisch nur einen Schokorand.
Murat, ich drehe eigentlich gerade.
>> JOSH: Murat, wink mal. Du bist im Fernsehen.
>> SALLY: Was machst du da mit dem Peppa-Wutz-Ball?
Also die salzige Erdnussbutterfüllung ist schon lecker.
Und Milchschokolade.
Okay, das heißt, ich brauche ja jetzt echt nur zwei Zutaten.
Ich brauche Erdnussbutter und Schokolade.
Und ich werde sie in Zartbitter herstellen.
Aber ihr könnt sie auch in Vollmilch machen.
Hä? Warum wolltet ihr, dass ich das nachmache?
Das sind nur zwei Zutaten.
Na ja, dann mache ich das jetzt halt.
Okay, also heute sind die Zutaten ein bisschen bescheiden.
Ich habe jetzt hier einmal Zartbitterkuvertüre.
Ich nehme jetzt 150 Gramm.
100 Gramm, also die zwei Drittel,
die schmelze ich jetzt schon mal,
gebe ich in so ein Schmelzschälchen,
hänge es über das warme Wasser.
Das Wasser hat kurz vorher gekocht
und jetzt habe ich es ausgemacht.
Und dadurch wird die Schokolade temperiert.
Das heißt, ich werde jetzt erst mal zwei Drittel erwärmen.
Und dann habe ich hier noch die 50 Gramm
und eben auch noch einen Teelöffel Kokosöl,
damit die Schokolade nicht ganz so fest wird,
wie sie eben jetzt ist.
Und so wird die Schokolade temperiert.
Das heißt, sie bekommt später keinen grauen Schleier.
Was ich hier noch habe, ist Erdnussbutter.
Das ist jetzt die
– warte mal. Ich glaube, das ist Crunchy,
weil sie so leichte Stückchen mit drin hat.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Ich persönlich muss nur sagen:
Erdnussbutter kaufe ich generell eigentlich nicht mehr,
weil in Erdnussbutter oftmals Palmfett mit drin ist.
Und ich bin dann eher so der Typ,
ich nehme einfach Erdnussmus,
gerade wenn ich so Porridge mache
oder als Zutat das benutze.
Also das wusste ich früher selber auch nicht.
Und in Erdnussbutter ist halt auch Rohrzucker drin.
Das heißt, wenn man sich da den Zucker sparen will,
nimmt man Erdnussmus.
Aber jetzt für die Konsistenz
brauche ich halt dann doch die Erdnussbutter.
Die gebe ich hier in eine Dosierflasche.
Ihr könnt aber auch einen Spritzbeutel
oder einen Gefrierbeutel benutzen.
Also ihr müsst jetzt nicht das nehmen, was ich nehme.
Ich mache es mir jetzt nur einfach.
Und die Erdnussbutter, die werde ich jetzt erwärmen.
Entweder könnt ihr das in der Mikrowelle machen
oder auch im Wasserbad.
Ich stelle es kurz hier rein, damit sie eben schön fließt.
Und im Prinzip
war es das erst mal.
Und wenn die Kuvertüre dann geschmolzen ist,
einfach vom Wasserbad runternehmen.
Wie gesagt, das restliche Drittel und das Kokosöl einrühren
und eben noch mal verrühren, bis alles geschmolzen ist.
Und dann hat sie die perfekte Weiterverarbeitungstemperatur.
[Musik]
Ich fülle jetzt hier die Kuvertüre auch in eine Dosierflasche.
Wie gesagt, auch hier einfach einen Gefrierbeutel
oder Spritzbeutel nehmen, das geht auch.
Denn ihr müsst jetzt
– ja, je nachdem, welche Förmchen ihr füllt.
Wenn ihr große nehmt, geht es auch mit Löffeln,
aber es ist halt schon ein bisschen eine Sauerei.
[Musik]
Und jetzt erst mal den Boden einfüllen.
Und dann nehmt ihr euch
einen Pinsel
und streicht die Schokolade auch am Rand hoch.
[Musik]
Wie so einen Cup eben, also wie so einen Hohlkörper.
Und das mache ich jetzt hier erst mal mit allen.
[Musik]
Ich habe das jetzt hier kurz auf so ein Blech gesetzt.
Denn das wird gleich in den Kühlschrank gestellt
oder eingefroren.
Ich mache jetzt nur noch ein paar Minis dazu.
Und da genauso einen Tropfen Schokolade.
Waren die jetzt oben offen oder zu?
>> JOSH: Zu.
>> SALLY: Zu, nicht? Okay.
>> JOSH: Ich lag falsch.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
Das heißt, hier dann auch wieder am Rand hochstreichen,
einfrieren oder, wie gesagt, kühlen,
damit die Schokolade fest wird.
Und dann kommt nämlich die Erdnussmasse rein.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier die Erdnussbutterfüllung.
Und die kommt jetzt hier rein.
Yummy, yummy!
Und dann kommt es noch mal in den Kühlschrank
oder ins Gefrierfach.
Und dann wird einfach nur noch
die Schokoschicht abgeschlossen.
Das war es eigentlich.
Ja.
So viel zum Rezept.
Aber ich denke schon, so von der Zubereitung her
– komm, das weiß vielleicht nicht jeder,
dass man das einfüllt,
den Cup zuerst macht, dann rein.
Oder, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm, das waren jetzt schon coole Tipps.
Jetzt fühle ich mich nicht mehr ganz so schlecht.
Und ich bin für viel Erdnussbutterfüllung.
[Musik]
Ich weiß es nicht, ob ihr den Running Gag schon kennt.
Und zwar ist der Tipp,
den ihr jetzt echt beachten müsst und solltet:
Also ihr könnt das ja jetzt in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Aber im Gefrierfach geht es schneller.
Und Sarah und Josh lachen mich immer aus,
wenn ich diesen Tipp weitergebe.
>> JOSH: Der ist halt etwas offensichtlich so.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Guckt einmal.
Wenn ihr die dann verschlossen habt,
einfach so ein bisschen klopfen.
Dann gehen nämlich die Luftbläschen weg
und ihr habt eine richtig schöne, glatte Oberfläche.
Ich glaube, wenn ich der Reese's-Hersteller wäre
– wisst ihr, was ich noch gemacht hätte?
Ich hätte noch gehackte Erdnüsse
oben auf die Oberfläche,
so Salzerdnüsse.
[Musik]
Also jetzt probieren wir mal.
So. Murat, komm auch mal dazu.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Also hier sind...
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hier sind die original Reese's.
So sehen die aus. Das sind...
>> MURAT: Heißen die Reese's?
>> SALLY: Ja. Oder Reese's. I don't know.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe...
>> MURAT: Ist das Englisch?
>> SALLY: It's English. Yes.
>> MURAT: Ah. My English was good.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe mir gedacht,
ich mache sie einmal in Zartbitter,
weil ich eher der Zartbitterfan bin,
und einmal in Vollmilch.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also ihr dürft es gern probieren.
>> MURAT: Ela, pass auf ganz kurz...
>> ELA: Ich habe das da von denen genommen.
>> MURAT: Pass auf: Das sind die Originalen, okay?
>> SALLY: Probierst du noch die Originalen?
>> MURAT: Und die hat die Mama gemacht.
Du musst jetzt erst das Originale probieren, okay?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Aber nur ein bisschen abbeißen, weil...
>> SALLY: Darf ich kurz einen anschneiden?
Ich will – ich gebe ihn dir zurück.
>> MURAT: Hä? Du hast nur die Schokolade.
Du musst schon richtig abbeißen.
>> SALLY: Ach, die Ela...
>> MURAT: Nicht so groß.
>> SALLY: Schatz, gibst du mir das Brett?
Das Waffel-Brett?
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und?
>> MURAT: Und wie schmeckt das?
Sei aber ehrlich.
Wie schmeckt das?
>> ELA: Das schmeckt irgendwie nicht so schlecht.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Nicht so schlecht?
>> MURAT: Okay.
Und jetzt probierst du das von Mama.
>> SALLY: Probier mal.
Ich wollte nur einmal zeigen: So sehen die innen aus.
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, ehrlicher als die Ela geht es gar nicht.
Jetzt sagst du, welches besser schmeckt, okay?
Was schmeckt besser?
Das Original oder das von der Mama?
>> ELA: Mama.
>> MURAT: Oh!
So.
Wobei das Reese's auch gut schmeckt.
Das hat einen coolen Hintergrund übrigens.
Weil ein Freund von uns ist der Robin
und der Robin, der macht den Vertrieb von
>> SALLY & MURAT: Reese's
>> MURAT: in Deutschland.
Das ist immer unser Standnachbar auf der ISM in Köln.
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
>> MURAT: Ganz liebe Grüße an Robin.
Der hat uns immer gefragt:
"Könnt ihr mal was mit Reese's machen?"
>> ELA: Hier. Mmh!
>> MURAT: Und wir haben nie Zeit dazu gehabt.
Robin,
>> SALLY: Wir haben es nachgemacht.
>> MURAT: wir haben es nachgemacht.
Es tut uns wirklich leid.
Reese's ist trotzdem cool, aber Mama macht es besser, gell?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mh!
Da stand doch mal dieses Auto, gell?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mit Reese's.
>> SALLY: Ich bin aber, muss ich echt sagen, Zartbitterfan.
Warte, Schatz. Wir können jetzt nicht alle essen.
Aber, wenn du willst,
kannst du auch mal von mir die Vollmilchversion essen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weil eigentlich ist ja das der direkte Vergleich.
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht,
dass das Eiskonfekt ist, was du machst.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich weiß, es sieht so aus.
>> MURAT: Ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht die Jüngeren unter euch wissen nicht,
was Eiskonfekt ist.
>> SALLY: Was?! Ich bin doch auch jung.
>> MURAT: Ja, aber die ganz Jungen.
>> SALLY: Ich bin doch nicht alt. Josh, komm, sag mal.
>> MURAT: Eiskonfekt haben die Leute
immer früher gegessen
und zwar – da schmeckt es ganz lecker – von Eichetti.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Eichetti heißen die.
Und zwar: Die sind auch auf der ISM, einen Stand gegenüber.
Und die ballern uns mit...
>> SALLY: Stimmt!
>> MURAT: Ja. Und die ballern uns immer zu mit Eiskonfekt.
Das ist so lecker!
>> SALLY: Das sind alles Standnachbarn.
>> MURAT: Ja, das sind alles Standnachbarn.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Also die Süßwarenbranche
ist allgemein nicht groß.
Das ist eigentlich eine kleine Familie.
Der eine bescheißt den anderen.
Das ist alles in Ordnung.
Nein, die sind alle lieb.
>> SALLY: Oh, ich muss echt sagen:
Die schmecken auch gut mit Vollmilch.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also mir schmecken tatsächlich...
>> MURAT: Aber
die sind so mächtig.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Also mehr als eins geht echt nicht.
>> SALLY: Mh.
Und ich habe auf der Webseite gesehen:
Es gibt die Minis, dann gibt es die Midi,
dann gibt es die Jumbo.
Also es gibt noch größere als die.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber das schaffe ich nicht.
>> MURAT: Nee, das schaffst du nicht. Also ganz ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Aber ich habe gerade schon gesagt
– Ela, Schatzi, das reicht.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wir werden gleich noch abendessen.
>> MURAT: So. Du gehst mal wieder hier Zähne putzen.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Nicht nach Süßigkeiten.
>> MURAT: Nicht nach Süßigkeiten?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Weil dann der Zucker den Schmelz angreift.
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wieder was gelernt.
>> SALLY: Immer eine halbe Stunde warten.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Was ich sagen wollte:
Ich mache nämlich demnächst, im neuen Jahr
– jetzt ist ja bald das neue Jahr,
weil das war jetzt das letzte süße Video dieses Jahr –
mache ich so eine große Reese's-Torte,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: die aussieht wie ein Reese's,
aber schmecken tut es richtig gut, nicht so mächtig.
Ich meine, das schmeckt wirklich sehr gut,
das ist eine ganz leckere Süßigkeit,
aber, wie gesagt, sehr mächtig natürlich auch.
>> MURAT: Und die bekommt man hauptsächlich,
glaube ich, auch an Tankstellen.
Also die hat es nicht überall, die Reese's. Genau.
Robin,
ich weiß, dass du die Distributionsrechte für Reese's hast.
Leider gibt es das nur an Tankstellen momentan.
>> SALLY: Ja, stimmt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Da musst du was machen, Robin.
>> SALLY: Du kannst dem Murat welche schicken.
>> MURAT: Ja, schick mir mal ein paar Reese's.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Also
>> MURAT & SALLY: macht's gut!
>> MURAT: Macht's besser!
>> SALLY: Viel Spaß im Nachmachen!
Und schreibt mir auch gerne,
ob ihr zum einen, a, Lust auf die Torte habt
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: und zum anderen,
was ich als Nächstes nachmachen soll.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Gruß geht raus an Eichetti,
wenn ich es richtig ausgesprochen habe.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß es nicht.
>> MURAT: Euer Eiskonfekt, das Beste, was es gibt.
Wirklich, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und an Robin.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Das ist echt cool.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ich würde gerne noch mal...
Ich blicke gar nicht mehr durch, was echt und unecht ist.
Was ist das? Echt oder unecht?
>> SALLY: An mir ist alles echt.
>> MURAT: Ja, ist richtig.
Ja.
Ist das jetzt...
Was ist das? Von dir?
>> SALLY: Das ist jetzt von mir.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich liebe halt Erdnussbutter.
>> SALLY: Die Originalen erkennst du daran,
dass sie flacher sind.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
Cool.
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Ja.
[Musik]